monsieur aimé césaire c'est le qui
a su dire en occident et au monde
je suis et je le revendique j'ai
donc et cuir ceux et celles qui se
compose de trois parties le rebelle
n'est pas mort première partie
j'écris ce texte car il y avait toute la
polémique savoir s'il fallait mettre ses
héros au panthéon ou non et le ma
conclusion est que son ambiance et sa
terre natale
il fallait donc monté chez lui
dans son sol dans sa malle
la deuxième partie sa français rebelles
parce que malgré lui
on l'introduit dans le panthéon en
mettant les pitas pourtant une citation
de lui alors dans ce texte jeudi
vous m'avez demi avec tous les généraux
raciste de bons à porte mais je
rentrerai au couloir et jeu parce que
dire un petit bonjour à mes copines leur
résistance et troisième parties il est
au bout de son petit matin il agissait
de retracer tout le parcours de ces
herbes et de la martinique tout le
parcours de laluque de monsieur 6 heures
et pour son peuple et avec son coeur et
je conclue en disant la mémorable phrase
de monsieur de la ligue 1 les meilleurs
spécialistes de la chose martiniquaise
son élément
début